le centre pédiatrique des codes doit
être restaurée implanté depuis 1952 aux
loges en josas dans un château de dix
neuvième siècle le centre prend en
charge de jeunes patients atteints de
maladies cardiaques respiratoires ou
encore digestives aujourd'hui
d'importants travaux doivent être
effectués les zincs de la toiture du
château et a changé
ce sont des châteaux qui avait un style
très particulier un petit peu moyenâgeux
avec des grandes des grès des tourelles
et des grandes cheminées donc on a les
cheminées qui fissure avec des risques
d'effondrement tout simplement de la
cheminée ou des tourelles et puis et
puis les terrasses d'été à des toits
terrasses qui vous font refaire tout
l'étanchéité en fait du toit une
rénovation estimés à 600 mille euros le
centre a fait appel à la fondation du
patrimoine pour l'assister dans la
recherche de fonds un dossier qui a
retenu l'attention pour son intérêt
patrimonial et architectural
l'autre partie c'est un projet
intéressant parce qu'il représente c'est
à dire le travail de l'hôpital
destiné aux enfants à l'arrière des
malformations cardiaques et c est un
sujet tout à fait important et
sensibilisateurs pour nous et on pense
effectivement que l'ensemble c'est à
dire patrimoniale plus sociale constitue
un dossier dynamique un dossier qui peut
avoir un véritable succès la collecte
était officiellement lancé lundi 22
novembre pour participer rendez vous sur
le site de la fondation